you go for a job interview and the first
thing that your interviewer says like
look you have great work experience you
seem like a nice young person but what I
really care about is your logical
reasoning capabilities so what she says
just sit down I'm gonna ask you a
question about some math expressions and
you say sure shoot away
give me some questions about math
expressions and she says all right so
you have two integers integer a and
integer B and she tells you that integer
a is greater than 0 and integer B is
less than 0 then she says that we also
know that a over B is greater than is
greater than a times B so then she says
tell me some interesting things about a
and B and a over B and a times B and you
say ok I'll give my best shot and I
encourage you to actually pause now and
try to think about how these things
might relate or how B might be
constrained or a might be constrained
and then unpause it so I assume you've
you've unpause it so let's think about
this a little bit so the first thing we
know that a is positive B is negative so
if I take a positive divided by a
negative what am I going to get well
this right over here a positive divided
by negative is going to be a negative
what happens if I take a positive times
a negative well a B is also going to be
a negative a positive times a negative
is also a negative so really what we're
saying is that we have two negative
quantities and this one right over here
is greater than that one so let's think
let's visualize that on a number line
let's visualize that on a number line so
let's say that this right over here is
zero this right over here is the
positive direction this is the negative
direction we know both of these are
negative but a over B is larger so a
over B is going to be to the right of a
times B so we know that a over B a over
B it has to be negative has to be to the
left of 0 a over B is going to be to the
right of a times B
to the right of a a times B so one way
to think about it is they're both
negative but a over B is going to be
less negative or another way of thinking
about it it's going to have a smaller
absolute value its distance from zero
which is another way of thinking about
absolute value its distance to the left
of zero is less than a times B's
distance to the left of zero but because
they're both negative and we're talking
about distances from the left of zero
the one that has a smaller distance to
the left of zero is less negative and is
therefore a greater is a greater number
so so far your interviewer seems
impressed so that was pretty good you
were able to get a lot of clues just out
of this little bit of information that I
gave you but tell me more tell me tell
me more about what what B has to be and
whether it's whether we can constrain it
in some way and you say well okay got
some clues here the fact that this
absolute value right over here is going
to be less than this absolute value we
know that the absolute value of a over B
is going to be less than a times B then
the absolute value of a times B once
again it's going to be a lot it's going
to be not as far left of 0 as a times B
is so that's how we can make that
statement but let's actually manipulate
algebraically manipulate this this
inequality here we could multiply both
sides times B so let's do that let's
multiply both sides times B B is less
than 0 B is less than 0 so if you're
multiplying both sides of an inequality
by something less than 0 it swaps the
inequality so let me that's why I got
rid of it I'm going to rewrite it so B
times a over B is going to be we're
going to it's negative we know it's
negative so it's going to be less than a
B times B if we just multiply it out
these cancel out we get a is less than a
times B squared well now if we want to
simplify it we can divide both sides by
a and since a is greater than 0 does not
change the inequality so we divide both
sides by a this becomes 1 and this just
becomes B squared so we're left with 1
is less than is less than B squared or
another way we could think about
if we think we could say well if one is
less than B squared that means that B
that let's be careful here and that
means that the absolute value of B is
going to be greater than one so this
means that the absolute value of B is
greater than one you say wait Sal how
did you how did you get from that to
that right over there well just just
think about this a little bit if I
square something and if it's greater
than one so that means that either B is
less than negative one because if it was
negative one if you squared it you would
get one if it was greater than negative
one or just directly greater than
negative one if it was negative 0.99
then when you square it it would be also
it would be something less than one so
that wasn't work so B has to be less
than negative one or B has to be greater
greater than one and because for the
same exact logic if it was exactly equal
to one if you squared it this would be
equal if it was 0.5 then of a B squared
would be 0.25 which wouldn't be greater
than so you know both of these things
are true and this this this is another
way of saying that the absolute value of
B is greater than one now we have our
other constraint that B is less than
zero so since we know B is less than
zero we can take this out of the picture
and if the absolute value of B is
greater than 1 and B is less than zero
then we know that B has to be less than
B has to be less than negative one
so wherever negative one is B is going
to be less than that and your
interviewers very impressed and she says
look you've done very good reasoning
here I think you deserve the job